bonjour et les coquerelles merci
beaucoup nous rejoindre mettre notre
invité politique ce matin vous êtes
député la france insoumise de la seine
saint denis et vous soutenez bien
évidemment le candidat jean luc
mélenchon on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre vos dons volant fabrice
henriot de bonjour merci la tronche à
brice du conjoint et brave bien
évidemment on va commencer par le cren
eric coquerel on parlera évidemment de
la marche de jean luc mélenchon dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est l'ukraine les
bombardements qui se poursuivent qui
s'intensifient même avec l'utilisation
hypersonique vous vous êtes favorable
l'accroissement à la france insoumise
des sanctions frappant les oligarques
aux russes est-ce que c'est pas un peu
utopique de penser que ça peut faire
reculer vladimir poutine dont je pense
que c'est même ce qui peut lui faire le
plus mal pourquoi parce que si les
profiteurs de son système
oligarques commence à être étranglés
financièrement je vous assure que ça
peut avoir un effet assez rapide sur la
base finalement de 2 sans pouvoir là
donc je crois que c'est plus efficace
j'allais dire que des sanctions globales
qui
de choses on dit les sanctions globales
économique qui par exemple c'était
l'idée de monsieur le maire il faut il
faut quelques pas frappé le peuple russe
bon avec un danger c'est d'abord ça nous
fera possible parce que les sanctions
économiques c'est lié au pétrole et au
gaz donc on voit bien que ça peut aussi
à savoir peur un effet boomerang et puis
la deuxième chose c'est que ça peut
aussi
soudé en réalité l'opinion publique
russe qui pour l'instant n'est pas c'est
pas vrai elle elle se tait elle est
soumis à une propagande absolument
terrible avec le pouvoir donc ça c'est
une chose à mon avis à éviter moi je
regarde les choses concrètes par contre
quand les oligarques qu'ils ont commencé
à perdre c'est le magazine forbes ce qui
expliqué qu'ils avaient déjà perdu un
tiers de leurs revenus si on les et rend
encore plus maintenant il faut y aller
vraiment plus fort qu'on ne fait
aujourd'hui jusqu'où à bas par exemple
piketty à propos de l'économiste a
proposé qu'on fasse un cadastre alors
malheureusement on aime beaucoup de
temps parce qu'on reconnaît très peu de
paradis fiscaux pour établir la liste de
tous les
russes qui ont plus de 10 millions
d'euros ce à peu près vingt mille
personnes en europe hélas tous leurs
saisir alors saisi tous ont fait pas
seulement la saisie un peu
spectaculaires comme ça a été fait dans
le port de la ciotat je crois d'ailleurs
on saisit tous je vous assure que ça ça
peut être des
déserts que ce yacht parce que pour
faire des saisies il faut qu'il y est
une infraction pénale et qu'il n'y a pas
une infraction pénale c'est pas grave on
dit que si on dit si des sanctions je
veux dire on peut le faire en dehors de
problématiques de sanctions pénales
contre les 850 millions d'avoirs gelés
pour le moment ils sont jeunes
il faut les saisir et surtout il faut
établir et le style de toutes les wii
bien sûr si on est si on pense qu'on
doit prendre des sanctions vis-à-vis de
la russie et notamment des profiteurs du
système poutine eh bien il faut le faire
je pense que c'est plus efficace et et
en même temps d'un autre côté je les
roule a toujours dit pour l'instant ce
que ce n'est pas ce que fait une aile
macron donc là-dessus il n'y a pas de
divergences sur ce point la france doit
pas rentrer en guerre parce que si la
france rentre en guerre on fait en sorte
que un conflit qui est absolument
terrible on doit soutient les ukrainiens
jean luc mélenchon l'a fait très
fortement hier dès le début de son
meeting en dédiant son meeting au peuple
ukrainien et aussi à tous ceux qui en
russie conteste le pouvoir de monsieur
poutine s'est guère mais si vous aussi
demain seger commencé à partir en
cascade entre des puissances nucléaires
on voit bien le risque qui serait pris
et nous on l'écouté de la paix emmanuel
macron a refusé de qualifier poutine des
criminels de guerre comme l'a fait le
président américain vous pensez que
c'est une bonne chose oui oui mais c'est
aussi oui oui et pour une bonne raison
c'est que quand vous présidez ou quand
vous pensez que vous allez présider le
pays jean luc mélenchon avait répondu
aussi à ça vous gardez d'aidé déjà les
dires des terminologies qui vous
permettent de continuer à discuter
malgré tout avec celui que vous
considérez comme responsable de la
guerre pourquoi parce que vous
réfléchissez une sortie négociée il n'y
a pas d'autre solution et bien hier pour
vous et moi ce que je pourrai rien
continue t il ya manifestement des
crimes de guerre - je
quitte qui ont lieu en ce moment encore
faut-il bon les établir de manière plus
certifié parce que vous savez donne
guère la propagande des deux 2 partout
une guérite mais malheureusement pas le
gdir le meilleur moyen de connaître la
vérité aussi
corus mais en tout cas il ya une chose
est sûre une chose est certaine non non
je vais pas partir seul sur ce verrou
m'emmener il ya un responsable
aujourd'hui qu'est la russie monsieur
poutine qui a envahi un état qui est un
état indépendant et et ça ça fait en
sorte que les responsabilités sont très
claires il n'y a aucun trait d'égalité
entre deux entre les deux états dans
cette situation la méthode la méthode
macron semble vous convenir sur le plan
diplomatique soit plein atlantique bah
elle même aurait mieux convenu si la
france était en situation plus forte
pour justement se jouer ce rôle possible
d'intermédiaires c'est à dire ce
qu'elles avaient une position non
alignés depuis des années pas derrière
l'otan qui par exemple aurait permis ça
nous continuons à le dire parce que
justement c'est peut-être les voies de
sortie pour la suite de cette guerre
mais qui aurait permis par exemple que
on écoute un peu davantage que disait
poutine depuis des années vis-à-vis du
du fait de refuser que quinze jours luc
raid rentrer dans l'otan si la france
avait pas être le temps je pense qu'on
aurait été mieux mieux situer mieux en
place pour justement jouer ce rôle on
l'a pas été donc j'ai jaillir que
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce conflit je ne suis
pas d'accord avec le petit monsieur
macron qui a consisté malheureusement
être dans les roues des états unis
d'amérique à travers le temps maintenant
sur ce qui est en train de se passer là
c'est à dire sur l'idée de dire on ne
m'a grave pas les choses on essaye de
continuer à discuter négocier
je trouve que il est plus raisonnable
une partie c'est de ses troupes que
parfois sont un peu plus va-t-en-guerre
que d'autres dont là dessus puisque sur
ce sujet justement certains des
candidats à la présidentielle reproche
sa position à jean luc mélenchon noria
nick shadow yannick jadot indique la
position mon alignement de jean luc
mélenchon revient à une capuche parce
que lis-je ado il a dit l'averse quatre
jours face à zemmour il a dit qu'il se
sentait non-alignés alors à jour il
critique le non-alignement de mélenchon
le lendemain a dit que c'est le
non-alignement qu'il faut bon je veux
dire il faut pas il faut pas je crois
qu'il faut pas récupéré à des fins
politiciennes la situation du cren me
semble que quand il ya fait ses
déclarations oui c'est ce qu'il a fait
d'autant plus qu' il faut aussi
réfléchir toujours quand vous faites une
campagne présidentielle mais peut-être
qu'ils ne songent pas à présider le pays
d' éléments dit c'est ça la situation à
ce que vous ferez quand vous arriverez
au pouvoir donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
rester à m'en donnait utiliser les bons
oh et prévoir la suite ce n'est pas ce
qu'a fait monsieur jadot en la
circonstance on va parler du plein de
résilience 25 milliards sur la table
pour faire face notamment à la hausse
des prix de l'énergie c'est le bon plan
pour le
quelqu'un met sur la table le
gouvernement non non déjà commençons par
la problématique des carburants bon ça
fait la deuxième fois que au met en
place un système qui va être très vite
j'allais dire qui va devenir très vite
caduque parce que le prix du carburant
continuent à augmenter ce qui est donné
enfin proposer aux français a vite été
avalé par l'augmentation du prix ça
avait été le cas avec l'indemnité
inflation 100 euros pour les gens qui
gagnent moins de 1000 euros nous on
avait dit vous allez voir si vous
bloquez pas les prix du carburant tout
ça va être avalée par l'augmentation est
le prix à la pompe c'est tout ce qui est
en train de se passer ici donc déjà
arrêtons de prendre des mesures tant
qu'on n'a pas bloquer les prix il faut
bloquer les prix du carburant les rangs
les ramener à 1 0 40 sur le prix d'avant
la crise alors qu'il a alors qu'ils
payent d'abord c'est les entreprises les
dix les rats finale d'il fall
distributeurs de pétrole comme total 16
milliards de bénéfices en 2000 l'an
dernier la moitié en distribuer en
dividende donc il ya déjà de quoi faire
c'est eux qui doivent faire le premier
effort parce que c'est l'eau qui
profitent de cette spéculation ce qui
est quand même un peu énorme c'est bon
qu'il appose entre parenthèses j'ai
entendu le merle gens les ponts de la le
bord de la mer pour la commission des
finances en m'expliquant que c'était
compliqué parce que si total on lui
bloquer les prix bas irait peut-être
vendre son pétrole ailleurs c'est
peut-être le problème d'un pôle public
de l'énergie je mets ça de côté mais à
mon avis et c'est des bonnes pistes bon
et puis on bloque les prix ont fait
d'abord payer les râles et les
distributeurs ensuite ci a besoin de
trouver d'autres l'argent revient
peut-être à une taxe flottante comme ça
a été fait pendant très longtemps parce
que c'est normal aussi que l'état ne
gagne pas plus au niveau de
l'augmentation des prix quand les prix
deviennent absolument aberrant comme
actuellement vous les européens bloqués
comment comment vous faites ça c'est une
profession qu'on a fait ici l'europe
fonctionner c'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire mais bon le problème c'est que
l'europe est un grand marché de
concurrence qui ne réfléchit pas
justement kino qui ne n'agit pas en
fonction des intérêts des populations
qui est d'aider les nations qui la
composent mais si l'europe était jaillit
des aphtes ce véritable outil de
régulation et d'intervention sur le sur
le marché avec la force qui est la
sienne force de frappe c'est le premier
marché au monde où il y aurait la
possibilité actuelle sur m6 vous arrivé
au pouvoir le 24 avril
proposant on le proposera pas fait je
pense que ça sera pas faisable mais en
tout cas ça serait la bonne piste parce
que l'europe ne profite pas assez
justement d'être un marché de cette
taille par rapport aux pays producteurs
sur le pétrole et le gaz russe est ce
que pour vous et enfin un embargo est ce
que c'est possible ben on voit bien que
non enfin on peut pas le tout la
question elle est le fait que si vous
prenez des mesures qui s'avèrent des
mesures boomerang pour le pays c'est à
dire qu'ils fassent en sorte que la vie
des gens dans notre pays devienne
insupportable
elle l'est déjà par exemple en termes
énergétiques c'est pas nouveau au bout
d'un moment je vous assure que ça va pas
être très efficace pour faire pour
bloquer la russie si on n'a plus mal au
coeur pour à l'évitement par contre il
faut peut être réfléchir très vite à des
as des as des mesures alternatives
parlera pas de façon à ne plus être
dépendant bon alors ça veut dire sortir
de du pétrole ça c'est clair ça veut
dire aussi réfléchir peut-être à
d'autres approvisionnements de gaz c'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire et puis
troisièmement aussi à long terme est
bien allé vers le 100% renouvelable est
faire en sorte de développer une énergie
où nous sommes totalement indépendants
ce n'est pas le cas avec le nucléaire
jean luc mélenchon il disait qu'il
fallait attendre de voir avant de fermer
une centrale nucléaire il fallait
attendre de voir comment on pouvait la
rampe l'énergie ce que nous disons c'est
que nous ne faisons pas nous fermons les
centrales nucléaires au-delà de leurs
lors l'horreur le recul leurs vielles
leurs annonces de vie l'égalité c'est à
dire on lit on l'est on les ondes on les
maintient pas donc ça va nous emmener en
gros à peu près vers 2040 2045 et donc
le petit que c'est d'être à 100%
renouvelable c'est le plan négawatt
2045-2050 possible de fournir les
besoins électricien sur la fin kilian
entre ses terres la pac nous dia watts
rte qui est le grand réseau de
distribution en france un ses plans
c'est la première fois un ses plans
estime que le plan 100% renouvelable il
pense que ça sera un peu plus cher ne le
pense pas parce que le coup d essai est
difficile à mettre en oeuvre non plus
mais tout dépend de la technique et de
ce qu'on met on met sur la table vous
trouvez que père c'est facile à mettre
en oeuvre boussaha multiples prix a
multiplié par trois il n'y a pas une
paire qui fonctionne dans le monde et
monsieur macro nous annonce qu'on va
aller vers 8 p r missiles responsable
aujourd'hui le renouvelable on sait les
on sait ce que ce que produire en scène
les problèmes qu'ont dasté elle pointe
du stockage mais ça on peut le résoudre
si véritablement met le paquet en terme
de recherche et développement et je
crois effectivement que c'est l'avenir
angers j'ai été il n'ya pas longtemps un
pays parce que je suis président de la
commune de du groupe d'amitié franco
islandais l'islande est arrivé à 100%
renouvelable dire et l'islande la
géothermie etc mais ils ont mis le
paquet pour développer tout ça nous on a
notamment un littoral le plus grand
littoral en europe au niveau maritime on
est la deuxième puissance deuxième en
terme de surface maritime je vous assure
qu'il ya de quoi faire dans tous les
toutes les formes de d'énergie marine
marine renouvelable annonce sur les
impôts puisque évidemment ça intéresse
les français notamment l'impôt sur le
revenu alors beaucoup de candidats
promettent des baisses d'impôts par vous
vous misez plutôt sur la redistribution
ça veut dire que tout le monde doit
payer l'enfant pour vous nous on a prévu
un plan fiscal qui fait que en dessous
de 4000 euros faisait gagnant pourquoi
parce qu'on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que
l'impôt que ce soit
l'impôt direct ou la peau indirectes
c'est ce qui est progressif équipe a eu
malheureusement très peu dans la
fiscalité je parle de l'impôt sur le
revenu fera beaucoup les classes
moyennes beaucoup beaucoup et que à
force de d'exonération à force de
cadeaux fiscaux je pense à l'iesf est
haute les plus fortunés de notre pays
bas depuis plusieurs années se voir
alléger fortement t1 de fiscalité d'eau
qu'on on est pour quatorze tranches
d'impôt qui permet d'y payer par tout le
monde peut même de manière symbolique
par des gens qui ont très très peu de
revenus ça peut être des fois 1 euros 10
euros 100 euros mais dans le côté
gagneront pas ce que nous proposons que
la tva baisse pour les produits de
première nécessité et nous proposons
aussi que
et nous proposions ça voilà donc easy
gagnon parce qu'en réalité la fiscalité
redeviendra plus redistributive est plus
progressive mais c'est vrai par contre
que il ya des gens qui au delà d'une
certaine certain revenu et paieront
beaucoup plus d'impôts et ça permettra
d'apporter des recettes et qui dit
recette permettra justement d'investir
notamment pour la biture question
écologique mesure avant de passer à la
réforme des retraites le smic à 1400
euros dès le 25 avril a dit hier jean
luc mélenchon il prendra un décret une
fois élu président de la république
comment vous financez et comment vous
expliquer ça aux petites entreprises
alors comment on finance mois déjà le
financement pour l'état ya que le coût
des pertes de ces personnels qui sont au
smic plus atteint certes un certain
revenu donc ça c'est pas du côté de
l'état qu'est le pleurons
effectivement des problèmes pour
certaines entreprises et bientôt c'est
qu'elle nous ferons la mer du cap et
gouvernement s'est à nouveau pas nous
serons d d d d aide ciblée aux
entreprises qui jouent en jeu qui qui
dépasseront ce pic à 1400 euros et qui
parce qu'elles sont dans un secteur
difficile parce qu'elles sont un secteur
soumis à la concurrence parce qu'elles
ont aussi une pression parfois des no
border ont discuté donc pendant une
période on est tout à fait disposé à
regarder a été ces entreprises et nous
sommes aussi pour un fonds mutualisés
entre les entreprises qui permettra
justement aussi j'allais dire de
permettre d'amortir c'est cette
augmentation opérationnel dès le 25
avril oui absolument on mettra très vite
vous inquiétez pas skis en oubliant pas
une chose c'est que ça c'est après il ya
un cercle vertueux c'est à dire que
quand vous remettez des revenus de vous
augmenter les revenus du travail vous
augmentez la consommation populaire vous
augmentez les carnets de bugs de
commandes des entreprises et tout ça se
met en branle il ya les cotisations
rentrer à nouveau dans les caisses les
pistes les fiscalités les impôts donc
c'est un cercle vertueux pour l'économie
mère globale dans le registre la
question des retraites emmanuel macron a
lancé cash 65 ans pour l'âge de départ à
la retraite vous êtes sur 60 ans est ce
que cela signifie selon vous qu'il ne
faut pas toucher au système des
retraites ah si il faut le toucher pour
revenir à 60 ans rappelle que gras avec
monsieur sarkozy on l'a mis à 62 ans
donc on est pour revenir à ce qui a été
là une des grandes conquêtes des du
début des années crs pour vous est-ce
que certains masqués pas réaliste c'est
de continuer à pousser à travailler dès
là à forcer des gens à travailler plus
longtemps alors que beaucoup sont déjà
au chômage ça c'est pas réaliste du tout
ce qui est pas réaliste c'est quand vous
avez encore plus de 6 millions de
chômeurs dans un pays de forcer les gens
à travailler à un âge beaucoup trop
avancé souvent pour les métiers qui sont
les leurs et d'avoir des jeunes qui sont
au chômage ce qui n'est pas réaliste
c'est le fait que en rallongeant l'âge
de 2,2 du travail et bien
progressivement les l'espérance de vie
est en train de diminuer c'est aussi les
statistiques qui le disent ok pas
réaliste du tout parce que vous mettez
pas en danger le système par répartition
non justement un coin des cno en plus
vous savez même le corps pendant prenons
la situation aujourd'hui le corps qui
est le comité qui travaille là dessus
dit qu' il va y avoir un problème qui à
2042 d'accord après ce les choses
s'équilibrent et jusqu'en 2042 c'est
apparemment il ya déficit estimé de 3
milliards d'euros ça que vous regardez à
trouver par an première d'euros à
arriver la trouille parents vous faites
par aucune loi d'égalité salariale
hommes femmes rien que ça ça vous fait 5
milliards de cotisations en plus il ya
52 milliards d'exonérations chaque année
pour les cotisations qui sont imposées
par l'état on va peut-être en récupérer
un peu et vous allez voir que les
caisses sont vides s'équilibrer
[Musique]
notamment mais oui vous étiez république
qui est rico créerez 8 où vous avez
besoin de bons sur toulouse ce matin
d'ailleurs ça vous est reproché par
certains médias oui j'ai vu ça oui alors
qu'est-ce que dix ans commémoration tout
même logique les apps d'abord je vous
fait mal qu'une chose là que la
commémoration de toulouse s'est elle
parcourt ans qui a dit vous n'avez pas à
relever mais il ya eu des des
rassemblements des initiatives à
toulouse notamment d'organisation parce
qu'il ya une sélection on a on a décrété
une une commémoration le vin et crimes
de méras etc du 11 au 19 mars le chef de
l'état a visité une commémoration de
laquelle il ya certains sont cons pas
été invité il le revendique aujourd'hui
donc je trouve est une dont nous ce que
je trouve être un peu curieux lorsqu'on
veut l'unité du pays pour dénoncer plus
que jamais les crimes antisémites donc
c'est un peu étonnant donc ses
collaborations ses adhérents du 11 au 19
passes y en a eu à toulouse où nous
avons été et c'est moi je dis atteinte
show d'accord jean luc mélenchon y
compris quand c'est arrivé avec des
phrases très forte dont on peut se
souvenir au moment de en 2012 jean-luc
mélenchon a toujours dénoncé de manière
absolument ferme est évidente les crimes
antisémites de de mera comme il a
dénoncé les apps toutes les attentes
antisémites qui ont continué par la
suite et attention récupération
politique de ça moi je trouve que les
gens qui jouent ce jeu là qui disent ah
ah tiens mélenchon a été la république
n'a pas n'a pas eu un propos le jour où
il ya une
commissaire n'oublie que c'était un
choix mais écoutez vous demandez à jean
luc mélenchon mais il ya d'autres bons
mois dans cette campagne laissez moi
finir il ya d'autres moments dans ses
campagnes regardez tous les discours ou
jean luc mélenchon a dénoncé très
clairement tous les tout tout tout les
dérives et les attentats et les crimes
antisémites donc là dessus je jeudi
gare à tous ceux qui utilisent ce à des
fins politiciennes voilà je pense que ça
rend service à personne
emmanuel macron il cette phrase hier
dans son discours à toulouse il a dit
nous sommes déterminés à combattre
l'antisémitisme et compris celui qui se
cache derrière le masque de
l'antisionisme est ce que vous êtes
sentis visés par cette phrase et non moi
je ne sais pas spécifiquement senti visé
mais par contre c'est une phrase qui est
une erreur alors en plus de sa soul et
c'est le propre de ce genre de phrase à
dire que si vous passez votre temps à
discuter à polémiquer dessus eh bien je
trouve quelque part que c'est pas rendre
hommage justement à toutes les victimes
je rappelle aussi les soldats français
avaient été tués deux confessions
peut-être plus ullmann d'ailleurs mais à
toutes les victimes de mera voilà parce
que là aussi ça renvoie un débat qui
mélange la question de l'antisémitisme
et la question par exemple de la
critique de la politique d'un état voilà
et je pense que c'est une erreur de
faire ça ce une erreur d'abord parce que
du coup vous relativiser l'antisémitisme
si vous la mettez au même niveau que la
critique de d'un gouvernement qui ne
respecte pas les résolutions de l'onu et
deuxièmement donc ça c'est un premier
problème est le deuxième en sais que
vous en voyez vous vous dites à des gens
qui qui disent ne sommes pas d'accord
avec la politique du gouvernement
israélien le fait qu'il serait
antisémite donc tout ça y est quelque
chose qui là encore est à mon avis une
erreur c'est pas c'est pas dans la
tradition de la politique française
vis-à-vis de de la situation dans le
conflit israélo-palestinien et je trouve
que là aussi mail macro aurait mieux
fait de ne pas rentrer sur ce sur ce
terrain votre marche hier qui a
rassemblé des milliers de personnes dans
les rues de paris jean luc mélenchon
lui manque il dit qu'il doit aller
chercher cinq points trois semaines pour
être au second tour est ce que ces
points et se trouve chez fabien roussel
est ce que c'est fabien roussel qui peut
vous empêcher natron steve moi je pense
que principalement ils ces points là se
trouve pas du côté de nos concurrents de
gauche voilà je pense que principalement
ces points se sont dans la jeunesse sont
dans les classes populaires les
catégories qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
ne rentre pas dans dans pour une partie
d'entre eux parce qu'ils hésitent à
aller voter dans ces sondages je crois
qu'en réalité il existe déjà je crois
que ces sondages sous-estiment la force
du vote qu'il va y avoir dans ces
catégories de la population qui vont
voter mélenchon les jeunes ils vont
dartier les jeunes des quartiers tout ce
qui en gros dans ce pays ont intérêt à
un intérêt premier à la politique nous
proposons que ça soit une politique en
faveur de l'égalité sociale de la
jeunesse une politique qui croit en
l'avenir il dit croire à autre chose que
le néolibéralisme et la mise en
concurrence de tout le monde y compris
des services publics comme le propose
monsieur macron avec l'école et la santé
dans son programme voilà ce que je suis
absolument persuadé que ça bon il y aura
peut-être aussi une partie aujourd'hui
des personnes qu'ils imaginent des
électeurs qu'imagine voté pour fabien
roussel ou d'autres qui finiront pas se
dire bah ça vous calme le coup d'avoir
un duel entre monsieur macro mélenchon
c1 a misé sur l'effet 28e sur un vote
qu'on appelle à voter efficace qu'on
appelle expression parce que le vote
utile on en a été victime pendant très
longtemps qui était l'idée de dire on va
il vaut mieux voter socialiste même si
vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord avec le
ps nous ce qu'on veut c'est un vote
efficace sur notre programme voilà mais
encore une fois je vous assure je pense
que c'est d'abord les absences you
potentiel abstentionnistes qui font la
différence
d'un champ 10 ans gouvernera avec tous
ceux qui veulent gouverner avec nous
mais c'est clean doute on vous avait été
critiquée à gauche dans cette campagne
bat déjà c'est peut-être justement tous
les acteurs des mouvements sociaux
syndicaux dont une partie se retrouve
dans l'union populaire je vous le
rappelle on a parlé moins au populaire
la moitié des membres des artistes des
syndicalistes et des militants
écologistes sont là et puis ça serait
aussi toutes les formations qu'ils
souhaitent vous parliez de fabien
roussel tout à l'heure si parti
communiste au deuxième tour souhaitent
soutenir jean luc mélenchon il souhaite
soutenir le programme et avoir des
candidats avec nous dans le cadre
justement de l'avenir en commun ils
seront les bienvenus et on y travaille
on travaillera ensemble donc toute la
porte sera ouverte pour espérer
justement former une majorité dans ce
pays et changer changer de moments et
changé deux périodes merci eric coquerel
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin
[Musique]